the Comedy Store would like you to know
that the views and opinions expressed on
this podcast are strictly those of the
speakers or authors and do not
necessarily reflect or represent the
views and opinions held by the Comedy
Store and its affiliates
welcome to Calvin a short podcast guys
are a group Elinor Carrigan we got mr.
Bobby Lee with us today thank you so
much for having me
hey Bobby how I like to start off by
asking a question is it okay yeah are
you in or Elinor you and I are good no
no no because I haven't talked to Elinor
in a while like 17 years 17 not [ __ ]
kidding you she is so serious
she's the longest grudge I one guy babe
it's not a grudge but I've ever had yeah
cuz both ways wait a minute you said
both ways and he's like oh she hates me
like in this my sweet and rightfully so
is it it well let's start with okay this
is what let me start this no I was going
into this Rick you're like you should
wore black and white t-shirts you're
gonna have to be a [ __ ] referee right
this what happened a couple weeks ago I
said to this is friend no no no I said
to my friend Lauren you member lauryn
he's working okay
so I said to Lauren hey I was thinking I
haven't Bobby Lee on the podcast and
talking it out and I go but do you
remember what the fight and she freaked
out you don't remember what the [ __ ]
fight was over and all that that Laura
yeah she'd out and I was like wait what
there was a lot there was a lot of what
the initial the initial one yeah the
initial one was a staff related thing
and that's a normal thing right
and I I will completely admit I did that
yes I mean what she's talking about I
did that I did not I did not hit anybody
I was very never hit me I know it's
really hard for me not to hit yeah
especially back then yeah yeah cuz I'm
fresh out of South Philly Elinor um if
you don't know was um
she's been part of the Comedy Store for
many many years as long as I've been in
LA right head waitress yeah talent
coordinator stand up stand up yeah she's
only she's immersed into the yeah the
car wreck
let's show our use I am too fair to not
have a fight
hi I know land I've had also battled
with Shaffir sure
I have several battles we hit you he
didn't mean you you have a rail oh I
have a battle robot right are you still
battle oh yeah what does look at what
we're done we have one of those too well
I mean we're not battling but we had a
little yeah
but Eleanor this is the big one for me
really because is this your 13th step no
understand but I've been waiting for
this for 17 some resolution not
resolution I just don't I don't want it
to be that way
well here's the thing when we talk and I
talk to Lauren what a couple weeks ago I
was like that's a really stupid one like
I understand the Freddy stuff and it
gots to ya later and there was a lot of
whatever all those years hands yeah
that's that aside I was like I don't
even don't take this the wrong way
I don't even think about this [ __ ] yeah
yeah I mean my dad fought in Korea I
block it I I know really that goes
here's the thing and I misinterpreted
her her her comma like her sense of
humor okay because she used when I first
came to LA she's just David state say
stuff like oh you know your I grew up in
Philly and your people used to eat [ __ ]
balls from the train oh that's a real
thing that's a rarity right that's a
real thing I always thought that that
was an attack like oh no I worry we eat
[ __ ] well I just want the [ __ ] balls
were I don't know you won't worry guys
they put it in the [ __ ] suit with
their [ __ ] balls and trees their entries
they're little balls they fall off the
trees and then the lady they're not
seeds no the ladies they pick them up
and my mom used to freak out if we play
football and them can't get that smell
out of your clothes why is it bird [ __ ]
no their balls are like little balls but
when an like Wow animal what [ __ ]
animal aside from Asia what animal say I
don't even the tree yeah the ladies pick
it up right one day it's like a fruit or
something don't know it doesn't smell
like a fruit really slimy I don't know
so I said to the lady I'm sorry I said
to the lady I go what do you do with
them because we always called them [ __ ]
balls because they smell
like [ __ ] smart so she goes uh she goes
we make a soup so you're eating me ship
wasn't labor yeah yeah I freaked out and
then do you know what kind of Asian she
was does that now she was Vietnamese cuz
a lot of well that explains it no I
didn't say that I met what you say I'm
saying but I didn't say that I know you
felt it I felt you feeling that no you
said well you know we're we're very open
but see here's what it is is that so
when I first came to LA yeah she would
say things like that
why do you guys eat [ __ ] balls in my you
know the way I'm so sensitive
yes you are I was also you know
understand I'm young I'm hungry all
Korean sensitive or just yeah we're
sensitive people you know people were
also a lot of things but we're sensitive
yeah we're an emotional people
really yeah but I'm extra sensitive and
when she used to say that I used to go
and we work together he was a door guy
here oh yeah we tour in San Diego first
yeah yeah and then me and Freddy like
Soto right right we all work together
right and so what happen hang out right
and then what happened was Freddy which
I don't want to talk about it because
okay I'm just saying I know I wake up
that's why I'm talking to ya but see if
I can bring him back
my hand is the basement for a reason if
you don't know is Freddy Soto probably
one the best comments yeah I stores ever
yeah he really was I'm dynamic he gets
honest very good yeah he's a very good
comic and him and I were friends at one
point when I was in San Diego he used to
drive mitzi around in the data prompting
and yeah and I use it was an open
microphone San Diego he was in LA we're
kind of around the same kind of time you
know when we started right friends and
then I came to LA and then I don't know
what happened
like he just wait really you don't know
what happen well I mean what he's love
there's no I'm glad was talking about it
and learning grow from here this you get
are you alluding the fact about the the
jokes
those jokes there was the whole Carlos
thing I mean I'm not gonna Delroy write
it because what his argument was is that
I was stealing his essence used he was a
saint
Freddie's like like if he was well you
have to understand though I don't know
though when I started ice like I saw
Margaret do her mom right exactly I
agree and so I would watch Margaret as a
kid I go I'm gonna do my dad rich out so
my first jokes were about you're my dad
now did Freddie do his better yes right
he committed to the character it was a
far more dynamic it but a lot of
dimensions to wear layers sure mine was
just the voice or whatever but you know
I was young at it you know and like in
LA you start yeah you know there was a
friction between us and it also is
stemming from a fight that we had okay
in San Diego okay so in San Diego what
happened was he used to drive Mitsy
right and so MIT seek you know Fred
burns you remember [ __ ] Ron Ron white
I think is not run white the other guys
swallow yeah I could see Ron Clark okay
he was the assistant manager and I and
they pretty much discovered me right
karate and Ron and later you know men
see and Pauly and those guys saw me but
you know the initially as an open mic or
they said we think that isn't yeah have
something okay so one day Freddy's
driving down Mitzi sure and she just
says I'm gonna fire everybody does that
sound like Harry more so we were just
easily Sophia I know fair and uh you
worked at in La Jolla living with Leo
working little okay I didn't know you
work there's and predator being Freddie
being you know an employee also Mitzi is
a very difficult I'm sure I love her
beloved friend she loved Freddie yeah
but it's like I've had conversations
with Mitzi too and it's very difficult
you know it's a one-way conversation for
sure with all that yeah we don't like
that right I mean consistent yeah here's
and you know also you know you don't
want to say something that's gonna like
cuz she she'll turn on you yeah she'll
turn
right yeah but I didn't know Mitzi at
that specific time when um I wasn't paid
regularly at the time so when he was
driving her down she was saying I'm
gonna fire one down there I loved
everyone down there because I started
down there right and I felt that Freddie
should have defended Fred Burns right
great and it but they had also
frequently only that but I also I woulda
said anything either
right if Mitzi said something like that
I'd be like so everyone looking at you
them yeah I mean you know why put
yourself so yeah man I got in and we're
in the condo that night when she fired
me she fired if she really did fire
every day yeah it was a constant it
would happen a lot sometimes she would
hire them back yeah a good day later
when she moved the club and thought
about member that yeah with Schubert and
Holtzman closed it out right yeah so
Fred and Freddie and I got a huge fight
about like almost shoving match I
believe you know if freddie was here and
we talked about it that that would be
this the foundation of why do it went
wrong with starting where it started I
think that I think that's what it is
yeah and arm me not knowing
Mitsy me not be a you listen I'm number
one I don't know anyone in LA I'm an
open mic girl I want to make it right
I'm an opportunistic person had nothing
else in my life
no college nothing yeah and this was it
so it's like you know with all those
things into play I'm not doing god of
do-or-die you guys know how hard
stand-up is right yeah yeah so I'm not
proud of some of the things that I've
done just survive all of us yeah so I
believe that that's and that came up
here and then so eleanor was Freddie's
best friend yeah and so and then she
used to the [ __ ] ball thing so the baby
something oh she's with Freddie at um
per she's doing it already yeah yeah but
do I am a book rate I know you are
everyone but I know you equally if now
you say [ __ ] balls I would laugh about
I'd say but you should see the things I
say
I apologize old Irish you know about no
other Asians or other people you know
this is the comedy game yeah right but
so I'm sensitive and all that stuff and
then so then Eleanor just I just stopped
talking to her we know we like avoid
about the door guy thing cuz my boy
Holly decided to hire Captain Kirk okay
I'm gonna can I defend myself with this
wait a minute
the kind of idea because it Kirk
fortunately this guy Kirk ran this place
in the 80s right and he did everything
and by the way he was high rekka and
that's in very important just listen
[ __ ] face this is not YouTube but the
people listening yeah very important in
the story yes because this is very this
territory taiga yes he hired a broad
another guys okay mr. Pete I don't even
know if you remember him don't forget to
work with him I know you worked with mr.
Pete uh he had a heart attack behind the
bar had to take him this year to sign it
crazy anyway Tony all those guys he
brought it all in Mitte
loved and trusted this guy with her life
even though he robbed her a million
times over anyway so he comes in and
he's he's like changing everything door
guys have to do this if a comic was ten
minutes late he'd send them home it's
[ __ ] crazy yeah he would not it was
gold almost beat him up in the kitchen
yeah I mean my my he went at like you
know like like an army like a military
right it was not the type tater of the
Comedy Store constantly was firing
waitresses he constantly was [ __ ]
with the door guys so we all kind of had
a secret meeting like we're gonna stand
up to this guy we're gonna figure it out
okay and there was only one person one
person that went to Paulie and ratted
out and started the feud between Paulie
and I okay who was it alright I did I
[ __ ] did it
okay I did it you're did it and also I'm
gonna say this right now I'm gonna
defend it okay okay okay because at the
time who was the talent coordinator was
it's got there I don't think Cory
it was Cory calm asalto so glory come on
so right is dating Freddie so ready
until no I understand that bug I
understand that especially cool now
exactly I understand that now ok ok but
at the time you thought I thought that
wow the comic that first of all the
hottest comic at The Comedy Store fairy
Soto
yeah he was number one guy right his
girlfriend is the talent coordinator
sure and I'm not getting spots where is
hidding wait you were really not with up
I was not and the reason why I did it
was because Kirk because he's Asian I
played that card and he would sneak me
up there oh yeah yeah so I would do he
would sting me up there and in my head
I'm like got a preserve you're you're
already a paid regular I was but I was
not getting spots and in retrospect it
was because I wasn't that great yet you
know and I you know if I could go back
in the past and tell my younger self
calm down right and coming from la jolla
de la is a bigger jump yeah like you're
you're in a bigger pond now yeah I did I
mean in a lot of ways I was very similar
in the way I dealt with Tommy he was the
only person giving me stage time and
like people are all like we gotta get
rid of him and I was like way to discuss
about that yeah you'd scream racial
slurs attack yeah but I mean you I made
a choice I'm probably wasn't the best
choice I did it out of survival sure I
admit I did it was understandable if you
weren't getting spots like see you gotta
understand I'm not a comic I'm a
waitress at that time where where I'm
for the staff and I'm for this guy's
[ __ ] over my staff my waitresses Jen
ready your guy I know [ __ ] was going
down gods accused to have freak outs
everytime [ __ ] Manson God loved him
you know but we used to get so [ __ ]
mad at Kirk right and it was sooo I'm
gonna call it a draw
no but I'm saying I'm gonna call you
know what Eleanor but Paulie and I
fought from that moment I'm sorry sorry
he told me to you wanna fire me
everything a draw it is I I feel like
it's a draw
um I could you could be more right than
me well we were just in two separate
camps area yeah because it's like you're
doing it for stage time and now as a
comic ya know I might have done the same
[ __ ] thing yeah but as a waitress I'm
like whoa I get it what the [ __ ] are you
doing this is the staff we had a deal
yeah turned and went to Paulie and I was
like just to get it like in my head I'm
like he just wants to get ahead a lot of
people would say to me oh you go tell
Mitzi that I'm not funny I would never
tell let see somebody wasn't funny yeah
we fire me right you didn't know you
never went to Mitzi and ratted on people
it always turned on you if you did that
think of all the people that would go
and tell Mitzi all the little gossip
yeah and she keep him in her ear for
like a couple weeks and then all of a
sudden she they never came again and
that's how it was she would bring
something up I would try to avoid it or
I was oh they did great or you know try
to be positive like never you couldn't
get involved in her life all you had to
do was [ __ ] because then you become
part of the problem absolutely because
then it was your fault yeah if that
person let's just say I said Bobbie
wasn't funny right which I've never said
that I know you know the way I wouldn't
do that
but that's their livelihood going
onstage sure if I said that to Mitzi and
then you got a TV show right I would be
into so much trouble but why would I
[ __ ] with that yeah cuz I didn't know
what was funny honestly back then
especially back then I don't really pay
attention to you [ __ ] up there I
write write give a [ __ ] unless one was
fingering me I panic right sorry reason
so I thankful and then I only let Jason
hearts do that he gets mad when I talk
about get more [ __ ] calling right yeah
yeah I don't remember
but I try to block you do I get sorry
Jase so arm i this is then this is um
it's it's a I open it for I hope I'm not
saying that cuz evasion but it isn't I
see that you're not not open yeah it's a
lot your speech it's because of my
alcoholism right I I think you know just
without going to meetings and being raw
you think you become the center of the
universe right and you make assumptions
about how people think and behave right
and then you react to these delusions
right so in my head I think that Eleanor
and Corey and Freddie are trying to get
me out of LA I literally thought that my
god that the world against against me
yeah and I have to survive because this
is all I have yeah so I reacted in in
these kinds of ways that's not the only
thing I've done done many things back
then right sure
and um yeah it's not you know I looked I
just looked in the mirror it's not to
feel great but I get it needed you you
were look at the survivor but I'll but I
want to say one last thing though okay
you can say hey I know I wanna I would I
have to be careful each I were not have
to say what I am not shy it in my
personal life okay I make a lot of
amends yeah I've always been like that
because of my 12 steps and all that
stuff right before or after or during
even during comedy okay except in comedy
Oh interest because for me there's
nothing more important if I've believed
somebody is getting away of my stage
time oh you know I it's my dream it's
all I have I really do believe that I
mean in terms of my like especially now
is defined to how this is how I pay my
mortgage right this is how I you know I
send my parents money
this is like this is everything sure
and I've always felt that way so when I
thought that somebody was getting away
you know I mean getting interfering with
my dream right I would react in very
North Korean type strategies tell me
you're a southern you tell me your
[ __ ] he's my second cousin
definitely [ __ ] shot my father miss
you should have better aim because ya
know when I see him I'm gonna punch him
in the face
just try missing that shot but I will
say this yeah as a comic yeah all the
all my everything changes because if
someone was getting in the way of my
stage time which by the way Tommy did
tell me because he was not quiet about
anything anything well and I don't know
if it's true or not to be honest but he
was the bobble Tommy yeah you never know
when he's [ __ ] lying or what but he
said Bobby Lee said if I pass you he
will never work in this club again and I
was like wow really is that real is that
true tell the truth I don't care I can't
give you [ __ ] sir all right I'm sorry
I think I'm looking off right I don't
think about it Tommy played that game a
lot that's why I'm saying what I might
have said it but you don't know if top
you know what I mean so I know I I don't
know I'm not 100% but it could be
something I said yeah yeah in my head I
was like you know what I don't care and
then one time I was hosting and this was
after I wasn't a paid regularly and what
I was hosting and you came in and you
wanted to work out early and I said and
Ari was here and you guys hadn't made up
yet and I go Ari
Bobby Lee wants it going next I'm gonna
give him a nice intro I'm the showman
professional so that he won't get mad at
me say I can't work at the store-bought
whatever cuz I get it uh-huh you were a
comic yeah now I'm in your [ __ ]
neighborhood yeah but when you were a
door guy you're my [ __ ] my understand
so I was respecting the turf because I'm
a hood rat and that's how we do yeah so
I remember I brought you want I gave you
this big intro really nice you went up
did your thing and articles you'd have
to go that far
assistant jerk-off art I was like oh my
god anything why that I think that's
what made me go here's what here's how
because over the like three or four
years ago if with you pursued say
Eleanor's name it would it would it
caused me a physical nausea
yeah I mean you know anak no not just
like like I'm sick okay right because of
all the stuff that built in my yeah her
you know man but then what happened was
she got passed right and then she would
bring me up a couple times and your
intros were so like professional and
kind of kind like like I'm not getting
me fell did not yeah people who were
like no yellow hands keep their me and I
would go up on stage and she would smile
and I'm like this is are we cool I can
phone me know what no I mean but that
was like the first time when I went
maybe one day right and then lately is
this last year I I really literally have
forced myself to kind of go be around
you not look at you but like I said no
but you said so many people say that to
me so weird but like talk to people
around you yeah Amen not leave
immediately I'll even look in and just
see what you do like okay she's still
there you know man and then just kind of
do that sure take you slowly tippy toes
wicked yeah you know I mean like this is
what is not playing and then the other
day you know man was the first real calm
I swear to God was the first
conversation we were really what did
last night last night yeah yeah
was just [ __ ] on his shoes which is he I
went home he brought them and wore them
again yes just so everybody know at home
alkali like you can't [ __ ] believe
what just happened
and she does what I go Eleanor asked me
to do a podcast I didn't even text pelts
cuz I don't want her to show up and be
like are you [ __ ] already broke I'm
kidding clutter goes no wow
yeah because eat Mike she knows yeah
right boy is [ __ ] about you
I'm telling you that you consumed me the
fear for seven years people are afraid
of me for fistfights but not [ __ ] and
we handle violence I just islands it's
not because I don't I don't like is that
it's because you know I know that when I
get it I know that you're a part of the
store your real comic now it's like
times have changed and its history and
it's all these things and you know what
everything that led up to this moment I
wouldn't change for the world because
you know we're all we're I I've done
pretty good for myself and I find your
lives are great so rate and well I don't
like great I think it is my life yeah
really yeah because I think that I'm
coming from yeah no you're right I'll
wait to be on a club to become a real
credible comic I mean it I equate that
to Theo von
going from alright one-man TV show road
rules to being a legitimate yeah
standing is almost so good oh my god
he's so good that's with him but yeah
I've watched you because I walk in and
watch you I wait him because I want you
to fail and I'm like oh [ __ ] she's
actually good yeah me and so now I can't
watch anymore right no I I'll say up
this was something that happened a
couple weeks ago and I talked about it
on the podcast and I said you know Rick
I don't know if you know this but I had
a beef with Bobby Lee I said and now he
just restarted it because I was on stage
in the main room and I had to go on
after Rogen and Greg Fitzsimmons yeah
right and I was nervous I was like [ __ ]
this big leagues you know what I mean
and a place was packed yeah and um I
text Holtzman cuz he was on after me I'm
like dude hurry up get here it's where
our spots are on time it's early and
then you came back and I was ready to
jump out cuz I thought it was Holtzman
and I was gonna be like 5 or whatever
and then I realized it was you and I was
like hey hey hey yeah you go I'm just
gonna use the bathroom and I was like
yeah no problem
like because I don't remember that you
[ __ ] right so wait so yeah yeah
so now I don't think about it he goes to
the bathroom I'm Fitzsimmons is [ __ ]
killin ya I'm like [ __ ] I'm sweatin like
you know nervous I go out and I'm out
there and I'm bombing a little bit I'm
like okay yeah I gotta figure this out
no sudden I start smelling something
okay [ __ ] took a [ __ ] backstage
now I'm vomit on stage they play you
smooth this [ __ ] you make me smell my
[ __ ] is like killing one yes I did take
a [ __ ] thank you I could I don't go to
the main room bathroom to take a pee
yeah I don't do the Lord the Rings
journey yeah I'm from the poor a lot
although I do that [ __ ] bathroom to
take a tinkle I'm like these people
think I'm [ __ ] my pants here
that's how you're saying you think it
wafted into the audience I really just
feel offended
hey [ __ ] I go this money I did that I
sure did that anybody [ __ ] positive and
think that it's gonna be so potent that
it's gonna reach all the way to like it
thank you
specifically ate the ingredients you
doing a lot right [ __ ] lol all such
thing as [ __ ] [ __ ] balls if you ever
bring up chip nose again we're going to
fill it open it no go to Philadelphia
and tell me one of this and I'm gonna
put him in a [ __ ] triple ziploc bag I
can't put that [ __ ] near my stuff she
has a Philadelphia to you it's funny
because I was just in Philadelphia
whenever I also go I'll send you to
whenever I go to the line whenever I go
to Philadelphia I swear to [ __ ] god
you're like she's gonna send her
brother's to beat me no but I do think
about you what because you're from there
that's right every time I fly into
Philadelphia it just it's a pop and I
live about eight minutes from the
airport Eleanor Samara yeah every I've
been there 25 stays in your mind where
do you play
helium helium that's me every time yeah
she's probably probably gonna bully me
tonight why she's probably got a bowling
me about the [ __ ] balls tonight I hope
she's not here in Philadelphia yeah I
want you to google it Eleanor and tell
me exactly what it is because I have my
podcast I'd like to talk about it I'd
like to talk about the [ __ ] balls of
Philadelphia the Vietnamese
I'm gonna put it off when we put this
podcast out I'm going to put it on my
Facebook to ask my friends in South
Philly because right about now is when
it starts falling it's just it's the
most wonderful time of the year the [ __ ]
balls are falling yeah
I'm not kidding it's that my mom's do me
a favor though Ellen give me a favor
when you first meet a in education
personal one don't open with [ __ ]
talk to Fung Shui upstairs all guys dad
talk about [ __ ] gooks okay I mean
that is a bru theist of the gooks right
with those bangs goes bang the bull
haircut I mean literally has each other
kpop it yeah I mean he just does the
football and Edwards Down syndrome
haircut yeah and now he wears those big
round glasses or sec - yeah this man how
you like a bombing that's what he does
when I'm on solving how you like a
bombing
I like them though yeah I love them yeah
I love war obsessed the other night I
was in the in the manager's office
getting my paycheck and one of the door
guys came in they're like but we have
free tickets they're like yeah they're
over there why he's like well function
keeps dropping in bombs he's a couple of
black people this is like a classic and
funny
he's someone he parked his car up on the
hood on King's up the hill oh yeah and
so Geron Horton and someone else on Park
and they they didn't you know say hi to
him they just watch walk away and then
they went over and they left a note I
was like [ __ ] don't ever [ __ ]
park in front of my house acting I was
one of the people that live there and
then they said if you have a problem
with it then call them some more racial
slurs give me a call and then they left
my phone no that's so far I get your
bronze like listen this might happen I
just want you to know we gave them your
phone number so that way someone we can
count on so the next the next morning I
get a text message it's like three
paragraphs long just talking [ __ ] [ __ ]
you you racist [ __ ] just going on he
knows your number he didn't know as I
thought
someone that is it did you say that it's
probably a police say that I'm a hero
that's it so I I just said back like
just don't park in front of my house
that just set him off again [ __ ] you he
texts me like a hundred times a day I
will never get my number
yeah you know why I made clear eggplants
yeah convinced it with the black dick
and all kind of [ __ ]
don't give him you know I love that he
has a child that looks just like him he
has a kid as a kid my soda he [ __ ] a
white girl yeah in Wisconsin oh is it
wisconsin' yeah I think so I had to get
kind of you know people had to know who
I was before I could do that ya know he
did that for my girls yeah it might be a
pink it might have been a anchor child
situation but it's you guys like this
like you know the commies door now is a
completely changed ya situation I you
pro con what what you're feeling my
feeling on it as a comedian is that it's
amazing and like spending a decade here
where there was really bad crowds I
still this was still my favorite place
I'm I'm sober now I don't I don't smoke
pot or drink or anything anymore
so hanging out here is is difficult why
it's very different because so there's
so many people everywhere they're all
wasted and it's not drives me crazy
you're not but most these people are
like a lot of the comics a lot of the
people are just hanging out there's like
nowhere to go hang out and just have a
quiet conversation with someone like a
VIP bar that was so CI Arizona just it's
like 800 people I've never met before
all hammered they should put a sign
there I'm being real yeah you have we
all feel that way dori regular and beers
whatever your friends are there I mean
how a paid regular and to friends yeah
like to carry ons like oh yeah I could
carry a yeah I'd be okay with that I
just like I walk in there and it's like
it'll be like nine people I don't know
they're like yeah Ritchie brought them
in here also can I say this can you we
have to make anyone that does it bring a
room here has to tell the comics that
are they whispering and my dad just
because you're playing here that you're
not
yeah I agree with that think that
they're a part of it yeah I prefer you
but we know we yeah we did we do Comedy
Store together I got no no no no no no
no no I am this is my family yeah you
know this is where I was pretty much
born my comedy you know and it's ID and
you your soul I don't know who you are
yeah it's insulting yeah I've had people
do the same thing like no no we
performed on the same night yeah yeah no
I didn't try marnark's room I had a guy
afterwards got a messy around the
circuit [ __ ] circuit does that mean
yeah dude
guessing the Sackville yeah what are we
talking about yeah the Catskills don't
even worry about it we'll see each other
around ha ha ha
it just you know it's like inside I'm
very possessive of this place too
I agree I'm the same way that you get so
much open Amy you started at this open
why do you watch you like what that you
mean upstairs even when you started
right you're like hitting and hitting
and hitting it everywhere you everyone
hitting and hitting on hideous it'll do
and you see you know over years it takes
so so long right yeah it's like don't
you do fleas all that work as if it's
nothing
you know you know and it's it's like
it's people just think assume I went up
twice
yep you're a am I an [ __ ] for that no
well I mean we might all be [ __ ] if
that's had a fight with a girl she's
like oh I'm a comic I go oh I didn't
know that I thought you were just
regular hangout she's like I was like
what was last time here on stage she's
like oh like 15 years ago
wow I go yeah what up kidding like still
hard
oh yeah hey you saw that yeah I go you
[ __ ] kidding yeah I think Brian
Swinehart was nightmare and he goes calm
down I go calm down
I know come on stage three times at
night my tits on the plane at Marty's
trying to get felt up by the mushrooms
at the Bellagio with dice
well that's different
this one I'm a middleman living living
the trail over there yeah I can and we
just did that
I open four wheels once so you know very
light all right chef yeah actually
either is a great chef yeah stream
stream loves uh chinks yeah wait don't
worry better
Mitzi's house no she was one of the
nurses great girl by the way she seems
nice she's a C still nurse say vermin's
make a scene one two I think he's
married to it that's still young yeah
but Hales I feel like he's got tied up
somewhere and I don't think that so it's
definitely a mail-order thing right I
don't know I met her once and I was like
you sure yeah she's sweet I'm in yeah I
met her two it's the same thing like
what do you mean wife I just like Tony's
favorite man like I always feel like
favorite man has like girls tied up so
cool
like one time I was in the hallway and I
was so proud of myself for a set I had
in the belly room this is like eight
years ago and I'm standing like where
that payphone used to be right near the
lake okay what a Mara and I was standing
there this people walk by and they're
like you were great you were great I'm
like oh thank you thank you and favor me
goes yeah in the belly room I was like
you [ __ ] yeah he was he was
right though you put yeah but at same
time that's part of to put your time in
that's not doing a [ __ ] one man enjoy
those kind of banter like when I like
when I got off a mad and I immediately
my agents like you got a headline but I
wasn't a headliner I could do 20 minutes
even that I mean I'd been doing comedy
for so long but just yet but I would do
it but then like rich vos and Schubert
and all these people would say you're a
glorified feature oh and I used to laugh
at that because I just like that kind of
like ribbing you know I think it's a
part of yeah this camaraderie and a [ __ ]
ball thing that she was bringing up but
sorry it's gonna keep saying she was
away to get she wasn't my equal in your
mind at that point so why is weak
response tables kalila kalila yeah
beautiful name thank you she's gonna be
pissed when I rub the [ __ ] balls on your
why was I'm just I want you to have
facts though I need I need what kind of
animal why they're part of a tree what
animal so this is
God [ __ ] no it's not actual [ __ ] it just
smells like it's a seed I think it's
like a date or something okay it's a
date probably yeah this is what's that
one freak was that one fruit in the like
in like Islands like it's it's a fruit
that people say it's I don't know I'm
sure America we don't [ __ ] [ __ ]
Island
I just [ __ ] gouge your eyes out
restart
yeah we can restart but there was
another thing a rivalry was arrested
that restarted I'll restart it on one
podcast this is what I feel bad about
because one night me and Brian Holtzman
were at the Laugh Factory right and I
was over there trying to smooth Jamie
and get him with at the Laugh Factory so
I was hanging we were hanging out up top
and I can't oh what's his name
good-looking guy Ashley Hamilton how do
I know I know what you're gonna say so
it is it wait is it does it have
anything to do with that I'm gay what
yes but this is what happened right I
just thought this is great this is
[ __ ] here so bad because again with
people not knowing my humor I don't care
if he gets up I can beat the [ __ ] out of
him just sitting down he's gonna get a
running okay so I'm hosting aggressively
I got justice what does Ashley Hamilton
a slab we're hanging out at the store
Ashley's a newbie I'm a newbie but I'm
old in that I'm already in at the store
this is this is George Hamilton son and
the guy that Ben Affleck's character and
Mallrats is based on are you serious
yeah I didn't know that I love Ashley I
miss him but me and Ashley were hitting
the circuit together whatever so we were
just hanging at the [ __ ] the big
circuit yeah yeah what was it yeah
vaudeville that's right and so uh we're
we were going up a lot together so we're
just hanging out and Holtzman somebody
brought up Bobby Lee I think it was
Ashley and then Holtzman goes oh he's
gay and uh he goes no it's not and I go
oh yes he is cuz now I'm playing a game
with Holtzman but then I realized wait a
minute Bobby's gonna believe that I said
this and Ashley was like you guys are
[ __ ] around and Holtzman kept
pinching me
and he was like just keep it going [ __ ]
this guy right because he didn't know
Ashley so I didn't think anything of it
all the sudden Johnny Sanchez comes
flying at me why the [ __ ] are you and I
was like oh my god I knew it
but I couldn't come to an apology I so I
oh yeah I mean so what happened on your
side I'm gonna tell you but I said I'm
sorry right now yeah I'm gonna tell you
something so I know actually yeah and a
couple of days later I see him in the
[ __ ] uh the kitchen upstairs okay I'm
sitting at whether you know me with
those stools I don't know if it's still
there those little silver where the zero
sign is to be right look at the bucket
sponsors right because do I UK and I go
no Holtzman's in trouble for this to buy
oh my the kid's name never came never
came up and I go no and he goes yeah I
mean Eleonora was at the Laugh Factory
just telling everybody that you're gay
that's what he said this [ __ ] now say
something right now okay I don't have
you read the [ __ ] book The Four
Agreements but words are black magic you
have to watch what you [ __ ] say
because you know rube through the rumor
mill it can like it can grow your let it
go man yeah get me have a disclaimer on
this podcast week I know we won so he
says that I go yeah it was the three of
us that's what stairs he's this is what
Ashley he's telling everyone she's
telling everyone that you're gay so I'm
now gonna like I'm gonna [ __ ] kill
this [ __ ] she's now taking it to a
level yeah now it's just lying to me
what my name okay she's trying to ruin
my name yeah yeah gay black listed as a
homosexual yeah right yeah because they
don't hire homosexuals in Hollywood
you're right there was another thing
that I forgot about if we reprimand okay
I know I felt so bad about it I realize
so fun is not part of our game
yeah
he doesn't understand the world [ __ ]
any other idiot dorsomedial in a Comedy
Store person are [ __ ] with us yeah
but it was literally the three of us
sitting up when he said it in a factual
way as if it was there's no joke to it
yeah she's telling little everybody yeah
that you suck dick and now oh here's
another one okay I've just thought of it
this should be good yes so one night I
was a doorman here right okay
and Andy day was here okay
yes and you think was drunk right and I
went in the bathroom the one right on
the hallway by the parking lot I
remember this rumor stopped right yeah
yeah yeah all right I remember this one
I'm not in the room now I'm in the this
bathroom I don't know the guy in fact I
don't barely even know who he is really
right I'm just kind of like out of it
but I know that people know who this
person is right he pulls his dick out
right and he got hey he was drunk and I
asked yeah I escaped the bathroom and
then for three years this is what I
heard cuz we face up Andy Dick's a dick
in the bathroom I when I was a doorman
uh someone I remember someone telling me
they're going through everyone telling
me that you know [ __ ] talking about
people and what part of the thing was
like that's Bobby and uh any dick in him
we're doing something in the bathroom
all right you know what kind of say
something I'm gonna say I'm gonna say
something right now okay I'm say
something right now I um I've sucked
dick before
so probably survivor I'm sucked puppy
five dates in my life okay okay
before the I was the age of sixteen was
one of the Mandy know wasn't any dick no
okay I've done a lot of bad things I
think it's not about that I'm just
telling you but like I don't have if I
did that I would say I did that right
you're not hiding any right there's a
lot of things out there when people go
he did this I didn't do that and I would
admit to it that I did it and I mean I
don't have that thing I don't care about
my past I did figure out that you didn't
do anything with Andy Dick and I'm also
sure
i rumor yeah they somebody saw you in
there did it I [ __ ] did that rumor
mouth the bathroom with him other guys
did I mean I owe you as you silly [ __ ]
yeah I'll help spread that rumor yeah I
did you not to me you never said that
done no they said it and I might have
repeated it alright alright
like he was calling the bathroom but I
did not start it I remember it could
have been any dick has a history here
cuz well you know any lying out you
might remember that Kenny Lyon yeah I
thought he was Asian for a long time but
someone told me a couple weeks ago you
want a Malin or something are you
serious yeah yeah so he's like a door
guy here briefly Bobby's little brother
oh yeah
Kenny one night the first time I met him
I'm sitting out on the front patio that
her it was a slow night [ __ ] I'm
sitting there talking with Pauly Shore
and Pauly goes on dude and I turn around
and Andy Dick and Kenny Lyon are walking
towards the comedy store from like the
Hyatt area holding hands and Kenny's got
a skateboard in one hand and aunty dick
is very tightly holding on to him I'm
just like what the [ __ ] is this like
sandy taking his little boy toy so they
come in and Paulie mate is like dude we
can't let him in and he he walks over
and just starts talking to Andy Dick
he's like now dude you're wasted you
can't come in here and he's Andy Dick's
making a big deal about it and while
they're having this conversation he lets
go of Kenny lion then you just see Kenny
kind of look around and like slowly
escape off scurry away so then like two
months later Kenny lion is hanging out
here more often and he comes up to me at
the back door he's like hey he always
calls me master Ingram I said hey master
Ingram would you do roast battle against
me and I go yes that's not Oracle I
don't know I don't know you all I know
about you is that you were holding hands
with Andy did and I feel like you it
would just it would be fair it's like
well but I think you're really funny if
I somehow beat you then that would make
me look good like yeah I don't know
think I saw the security guy upstairs
the Guam guy
I don't know yeah I love it yeah yeah uh
no cannot not a client met Jesus
yes skinny kid I can't holler high
school I did too sellin rlr can I ask
you a question about and this is getting
it really it might not be uncomfortable
by when I know uh what so I don't know
exactly how Freddy died you could google
it
no I mean I have tried no no honestly I
mean there's another thing - yeah but
like um so what I had heard mmm is that
he had taken ambien yep
he was also on cocaine no not that night
but he did fall off the wagon
in all honesty a couple months I know
the early you know I knew that he had
relapsed yeah yeah yeah so yeah he would
have called Baba so my what I had heard
is another comic had given Freddie no
cane comment love doctor no I don't know
allegedly because we already got trouble
for those things but but my thing is is
um yes he would get that and no um it
wasn't what killed him does that make
sense that was a rumor people like Oh
his cokes bad don't buy his coat I'm
like really that's what's coming out of
this I just wish not what happened
so we don't have this [ __ ] a thing I
could mean the addiction no just between
us and the enemy and that campus and
[ __ ] Cory because like I could I
wanted to go the funeral but I couldn't
okay and that was another thing like ran
is easy said to me
Bobby Lee asked if he could cut off
course he can come what the [ __ ] it's a
funeral like I will never yeah but I
just made an assumption that yeah I
would I would really party yeah right
there's a party on that party about
whether you Orioles yeah yeah yeah
actually a war with El Paso yes I would
ruin the the funeral no I uh I may be
Freddie Johnny that up Johnny's out get
out he may have asked you to leave but I
would ya kidding me I mean because his
memorial they had one at the storm which
I went to yeah yeah and they showed that
video I swore to fungi I have never
cried I mean I just it was devastating
yeah I cried a lot was devastating
remember people I mean I remember I was
with Ken Jong and Steve Byrne driving
back from San Francisco cuz we did the
punchline right and I I remember pulling
over right because I got a text and I
guess I just bet you know you certain
moments in your life will you remember
things vividly right I was one of them
and I just remember being like I wish
this is a guy you were listens with and
yeah I was I wish yeah I wish that I
could have been like we could have
smoothed it over right that's what I
mean like what you were friends then you
know yeah I really do believe I really
believe I believe I believe cuz over
toward the end we went to Hawaii
together yeah toward the end there was
communication and jabs and jokes and I
felt like this was going to be something
that was going to be under the bridge or
whatever well that we were able to maybe
not become best friend would eventually
have but we would we could have like yet
done work together and maybe something
to go or something right that would have
been great yeah you know so it's just
like you know I didn't get that chance
yeah to do that yeah I mean it was it
was one of the saddest things that I've
experienced and I wasn't nearly as close
with people but he was someone who's
always really cool to me and I remember
going to the was it Forest Lawn yeah and
I got really upset
and I just didn't like I didn't like
being around a bunch of comedians that
basically only knew me from doing this
stupid Argus impression all the time
because that's basically how I lived but
Freddy loved it Freddy loved it and so
all these people and I was crying and I
walked away and I just needed to get
away from people for a minute and
[ __ ] Johnny's app of all people shows
up in shorts in a pink polo he comes
over hey what are you doing
here like Johnny get away from me I just
you know I was gonna wear a suit but
it's just so hot like get the [ __ ] away
from me I was wearing a suit that I wore
to [ __ ] homecoming my senior high
school because I couldn't afford to buy
something newer than that I was so mad
it was it was a truly one of the saddest
things I've ever experienced seeing so
many funny people sad yeah it's just
tough but but yeah he was um he like I
told this story on what's his name Bert
Kreischer door Bert Caston and I got in
trouble from Carlos Mencia because I
told the truth and the truth is like
Freddy had already had he was struggling
with addiction naturally and and
whatever people go through it and it was
his third time falling off the wagon and
he already had like health issues fatty
liver all kinds of different oh yeah
yeah acid reflux and Freddy was a little
nutty in his little Mexican medicine or
whatever you want to call it but he
would take like eight advil a day and I
would be like one time I had my tooth
maybe a root canal or something and I
wouldn't take the medicines I don't like
medicines I get violent with or without
medicine but with medicine worse so I
said you know I'm not going to take him
from I was really bad pain I called
Freddy I'm like [ __ ] I can't take it and
he's like just take a advil I'm like
what are you [ __ ] high he's like no I
do that all the time
but the corners horrible fear liver that
dries up your liver yeah
horrible Freddy could do this twice a
day that's 16 [ __ ] advil yeah it's
insane and I mean he was in a lot of
pain with different stuff whatever so he
had that then he fell off the wagon and
right before I was with dice I was
dating dice at the time and that's
another funny thing well after we get
off this awful part we'll go back to
that but I was with dice we were about
to leave for New York and Freddy said
hey I'm gonna walk you through this
teach you how to go on the computer and
look up Carlos Mencia is mind of Mencia
so I was like okay so look it up and the
promo like say if it had five jokes in
there for them were Freddy's brand-new
bits
and he was he goes I'm beside myself I
can't take it I quit
[ __ ] this just angry yeah Carlos oh he
uh he was angry and he yeah he got mad
that I brought it up and he emails you
sent Eleanor an email where he was
trying to play the victim and be
basically like oh I thought we were cool
and you're two-faced and not to face
them eyes yeah he did that there's no
denying that right
am i lying I mean I I mean I I
understand if you don't want to I never
I've said it before and I have I've you
know there is a part of me there used to
be a struggle because of the fact that I
know that Freddie and I a lot of people
initially in the beginning of our
careers he we opened for him absolutely
Carlos yeah said he carlos feeds me he
goes I respect him too much yeah
confront him right but he would
blatantly tell him I'm taking your [ __ ]
yet you would I mean you would ste see
him do things that were stuff that I
thought were was wrong or you know and
it's it's like that they same thing
about Mitzi but yeah you've read being
able to really say how you feel because
it's gonna hurt you you feel like they
don't have a power right there more
power sure they do and they can do
something you know yeah so you don't you
know but I mean obviously I have seen
all kinds of [ __ ]
you know and I've seen him and behave in
ways that in the world he was on
meirin's podcast talk about he works he
was openly talking logic it was I could
make it better anymore yeah yeah I mean
the one thing he did with the Johnny
Sanchez thing at uh funniest funny okay
loco do you hear that where where he was
hosting it and Johnny his whole act in
his whole five minute set was gonna be
this is a TV is gonna be about the
Persian you know yeah and their King at
my pride and Mencia
does it before him oh I'm not exactly
were forward obviously but the system
provides a premise idea right
so that Johnny couldn't pick it didn't
work right and he knew Johnny knew that
he was gonna do that Wow
you know so it's like you see but I
struggle because he called me a month
ago you can't mind me you know it was a
matter because hey dude hey bro
like what this time what you said about
me on Joe Rogan's podcast was like wrong
dude I go I have a despot in three years
yeah that one is three years ago yeah
like he out of nowhere it right yeah
like he's googling yeah yeah and so I
and then he says the means do something
you know Amy Schumer was right when that
was happening she refused me yeah if she
gets a free pass I go it's not the same
yeah yeah I don't know why he doesn't
misunderstand waters talking about like
what people are talking about yeah yeah
lie to yourself people convince
themselves of anything to live with
themselves yeah that's that's human
behavior I mean speak of paranoia
I remember Freddie being on stage in the
main room killing 9:45 I was waiting
tables right in the front like Section C
that's not going to mean anything to you
but right in the front and I'm putting
drinks down and he stopped his show and
you'll remember and he asked you to
leave because he was afraid you were
recruiting for Carlos right no I thought
he asked me to leave I remember Jeff
Scott pulling me out of the room well
because I do all looked like what do we
do by us right now I thought that he to
kick me other room because he thought
that I was not feeling that Carlos was
his mate that's what my mind right that
wasn't clear at that moment now I
distinctly remember that yeah I think
was in the main room it wasn't me it was
in the main room Patti was back I go in
there he stops
he points to me get him out and get him
on the room me and Ira my god it was
awful I I remember being like what the
[ __ ] yes I will trying to get my drinks
out as fast as possible cuz I thought if
I have to fight I have to fight yeah
yeah I mean I know in a crowd you know I
know but you notice is the crowd just
looking around like what the [ __ ] is
going on or is it like yeah you know I
was part of the Attic Donnie Gill but
still but again it's paranoia because
it's my own paranoia in his head he
built that there was he knew when he was
with Carlos you know you work for Carlos
and that's yeah and at that time you
were still with him yeah so it was he
was like he's gonna bring it back to him
and he was working on all new [ __ ] so he
was like [ __ ] this I'm not yeah
oh my [ __ ] away yeah that was a tough
one I remember that vividly - it was it
was it was really tense and I was like
fine and like the door guys were like
what do we do cuz yeah again check out
one of our guys not paid regular forget
that but our guys where we all worked
here to get I it has to be me though
what do you I'll tell you why because I
don't know I'll have to go to therapy
for it but you mean your own paranoia no
it's it's that I'm always in the middle
of yeah but are you a people please no I
mean in San Diego even like with Fred he
stopped talking to me because I was in
battled in the middle of a full-blown
war Civil War and I was the center of it
when I come up here like because when
Fred was oh no when Fred when Mitzi
moved the club she laughed but then Fred
took the club back over so there was two
comedy clubs in La Jolla right I had to
make a choice between the Comedy Store
or Fred Burns Club and I chose a store
and then all of a sudden my most hated
person in San Diego as a comic where one
comic just slapped me in the famiiy was
crazy and they come up here I was in
battled in that because there with Ari
Shaffir embattled on that right I I must
be a character or somebody that's like
you know that that like one
that needs this kind of chaos in action
i'ma gonna fight you on you being
terrible but I'm kidding I know I'm
serious like I understand what you're
saying but it's a drama thing like it's
it could be that you just but I also
have done good I know the thing I've
done great things too you know man so I
don't know I but you know what in the
last I think five or six years nothing
really yeah after they already think
that it was been fine you know so who
else there's nobody else me that's it
no I battled with you Fred burns like I
said I was in the middle of the Mencia
rogen you know you know I remember that
and I remember that off I got pulled
into that one too tough
I remember Carlos telling me something
about how you know he was getting I
think he said he was gonna get my
representation to drop me and I said
have any representation oh yeah
is a yeah well you're not going to I was
like what [ __ ] you talking about I mean
and I never got representation Oh see
maybe he doesn't pull but Holly told me
I'm never gonna work in this town again
he might have some pool damn that you
working no no I think he was promoting
his movie you ever wheeze in this town
when what might you know I have the same
agent as Matt I mean as Carlos you know
that right eight which one oh is that
where you can say no I'm with CA okay oh
it's CAA okay and I just didn't know who
he was with because I'm thinking of his
manager yeah and um I mean I was asked
how do you how do you reinvent his
career Carlos and I told them my opinion
would be and I think it's a genius idea
which is I do believe that if they did a
documentary of him going to clubs
writing jokes you know me you see him
through the writing process of actually
coming up with you know there's a
there's broad premises but there are
specific things that you can talk about
like your own sister or your family
right that you can't get from some
rights based in reality you make it so
very personal and real yeah
and you see him work it out and at the
end of the documentary he does it right
I'm not saying that he would win back
mom but he's either a 20% maybe people
well yeah I was good you know you know
he and now he's trying you know but but
then it's like he has to truly admit
though first of all that he did though
did those things yeah but I thought he
did I thought he went on Marin and he
was like I did I did it on purpose I
would bump them to show them that I'm
helping people's one thing that yeah I
would say and I could do their material
better than that yeah leader that's not
admitting yet now but now he there's
certain things he defends and he's he's
he if if I was him I would just I would
say I stole all these jokes okay maybe
he don't remember honestly what he stole
he's mad he's that [ __ ] up who knows
there's a lot of people accusation so I
mad and it is hot I always say this when
I talk about Ned is that but he's done
so much for me that it's a very
difficult thing to talk about
that's how Freddie felt yeah I love us I
do love him yeah it's it's crazy to say
but I do love the guy yeah but did he
rob from you or steal from you like that
cuz we're Freddie he would call me from
the road and be like he told me he's
doing this this and this yeah have any
bits yeah I give them [ __ ] Ronnie
Kenny jokes yeah all right whatever
jokes about 22 yeah I mean it you know I
it's uh it's it's something that I'm
like Ronnie
sorry Ronnie deal wedding heading for
the just my whole yeah career is just
juggling this thing between Ronnie and
Erica yeah it's just it's crazy because
I'm now I love Joe Rogan yeah you know
like I have you know I've now and I are
very good friends Joe you know that
whole thing Ari's gonna be very happy
about this great
I think Ari will be great for happy
about this you know I've done you know
re just out of the blue four years ago
said five years ago said I'm gonna
squash it we met
we squash it I love the guy yeah you
know really I do
oh I'm just can I do and I think with
Eleanor I don't know best friends but I
don't also never gonna have it but I
also did want to come to a club and be
able to feel comfortable not a
comfortable but be able to go hey I like
that joke right to her or you know I
mean just have a social crowd yeah that
you got there you know me and I that's
what I want yeah you know I'm not here
to you know be best friends with
everybody but I know that she has worked
really hard to get to where she is right
she really has either I mean I wanted
her to fail thank you you know she went
against I mean everything she's done
yeah you know is i ha [ __ ] like she did
it right yeah so it's like that's what I
want and that's why I'm here that's all
you know arm I mean this is by far been
one of the most personal sorry podcast
that we've done just in general which is
awesome like is so seniors day yeah yeah
one of my favorite realize it was that
like that's that deep one of my favorite
fights with dice and we fought a lot
when we were dating we still fight we
had a fight yeah they in New York I'll
fight him right now and but that like we
argue a lot remember when he was going
through a divorce and he turned this
place into a [ __ ] soundstage bass
always had it was a circus yeah it was a
circus it was dicen el Circo yeah I mean
he'd be like I need you like ran is easy
Rick they'd be like we have to see
people we thought like oh yeah I have
drinks melting and he's like you got to
finish this scene I'm like I got to get
these [ __ ] drinks out yeah I thought
Mike black was a stuntman
yeah I mean like hey I don't know about
that he changed although my turned into
like yeah course AZ like he was walk
through this you know mean a new head
yeah so he puts you in a scene yeah my
name and then we go home and we watch
the dailies yeah so we got it yeah so
watching the dailies and your scene came
out yeah and not intentionally or maybe
intentionally I don't know I got up and
I went to the bathroom yeah and then
asked intentional alright your programs
clearly attention clearly intentional in
my head yeah yeah the bath I don't think
about I go and then I go slow
sure yeah I come back and he's like he's
fuming he's like you're trying to ruin
my show because you don't like Bobby Lee
oh wow are you
he stood up for you I got this
[ __ ] yeah I don't know didn't
know what happened yeah you get it he's
just like look it's and trying to
explain them and Max and Dylan - yeah I
mean like I feel I love those kids
yeah I really do I talk to them whenever
I and I said go tell about your CD you
know what yeah I really do like those
guys I'm super talented they turned out
amazing but I thought that I could be I
would have been closer if it wasn't for
her you could have no kebab' so crazy my
head yeah like I could have been you
know man no they love you stepbrother or
whatever right I will tell you that they
have no idea we have a beat I understand
that and whenever I see them
it's as if nothing it's fine you're not
saying that you [ __ ] did anything I'm
just letting you know you're telling you
like I'm like by reinfected Brea but um
you know I mean I've always and Di's
I've always yeah and I sledge we don't
never legend yeah he wouldn't and he
loved Bobby and that's why I love him
because I remember at the Bellagio
uh-huh me and Jim Norton open from okay
and you was this you were there I'm
kidding
cuz yeah you were backstage with the
kids and I saw eating yeah you Andrea
okay and I saw you you had Dylan was
smaller
you had his armor on him
and they were this one becomes seem is a
high but you I think you pull Dylan back
no yeah and I'd never do that you know
why cuz he hears about me it was in my
hat Andrew kill me I was running around
going this way and I Andrew was on your
side buddy not mine no I mean and that
was a great show with me imagine show
you want it no I was Joey Diaz yeah
and Jim Norton so just kill Roger over
the Stardust
it was the Bellagio for sure yeah maybe
to start us up I wasn't there you were
there
are you sure Eleonora I'm not I would
have thought now holy remember I even
like the curtain and I remember like I
can far away but I could vividly
distinctly see you right right and
Freddie was still alive no this would
have been post Freddie can't be possible
that's an impossibility one me because
oh he was still alive yeah because
Freddie must have been still alive yeah
yeah ready open for him a couple times
at the Stardust and Andrew and Friday
were really really tight so what you're
saying to me is this is that you
couldn't have been there because I would
have remembered you would remember I
remember Sebastian I remember bloke
Horton I don't remember you know is
either to be honest opening for Andrew I
know Andrew loves them and it really did
a while it's probably true like just
let's let you learn yeah I'm sorry that
was fine fine you know why don't we just
do this okay we'll leave that one as a
mystery no not what no we'll leave that
as a mystery let's have a mural nice
take a little see you design this the
tie see that little shitty seed [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] ball seed we planted a
[ __ ] bow see that stinking my grow up
into another [ __ ] ball another shitball
trod um I have to go yeah we thank you
fire that was good
we're gonna have to have you back only
because we didn't ask you about your
show okay there are so many things we do
I'll get you a cab
someday let what is it a little quick no
[ __ ] it wouldn't tell me what they owe
them don't like talk about remember your
showcase for mitzi forget you told this
is fine this is why I do one minute on
okay now let me start to show you one
right so I got past a couple years in
okay what happened was Paul IGAs did
your opening me opening up for me in
Vegas it was me wild Willie person is
not CD all denim denim dances went on
Ripper was the head of the entertainment
at Riviera sir shrimpers sure up is
there I didn't know who he was if you
don't know who steve Schirripa he was in
the show
soprano soprano i used to book the
Riviera for him oh really
Rick oh that's amazing and Ari and
Khepera Lou and a whole bunch so I
remember being I'm from living in San
Diego and I remember going and then
stripper going a Kiki you know he used
to call me King I don't know why but
because he's he's worried yeah and he
goes do five minutes and that's it don't
go over don't you know yeah he always
said that right so I did it and then
Mitzi was there and then that night I
saw her at the party or whatever like
after-party
she goes you're your pay regular and
that's how it happened Wow you showcase
at the rib and she was pissed that week
she goes he put me in a [ __ ] Murphy
bed oh yeah yeah that was like both like
one of those things where I went wow I
got really lucky there yeah yeah that's
crazy oh lucky yeah cuz she some people
she despised would she'd see him on
doing opening for Pauly like rent is
easy and re she got rid of the unpaid
regular position because she saw them
open for Pauly in Palm Springs and
without her permission
oh really yeah she odd no more unpaid
regulations yet re ruined it bye-bye
alright thank thanks Bobby
don't bring that don't take the
headphones [ __ ] check out Bobby
he's what your Twitter Facebook why
don't you get to the [ __ ] do it
tiger belly microphone what's wrong with
you check me out on the tiger belly
podcast
follow me on
Bobby Lee live Instagram and Twitter
please I want to plug a couple of things
since I'm here
yeah it says um I have a couple of
scenes of that movie keeping up with the
Joneses watch that I'm doing second
seasonal love thank you beautiful home
man you did some man TV right thank you
just do some magic god damn it I'm so
happy he's going Rick now we can really
do the punk yeah that was let's get
started
the truth so truth serum we'll call now
well thanks for listening guys a Rick
Ingram I'm Eleanor Kerrigan thanks for
listening come to the conference or
check out some shows bye
you